know that higher inflation and interest
rates cause anxiety and concern for many
families
that's why the government is already
supporting families with one of the
largest support packages in Europe worth
94 billion pounds or 3 300 pounds per
household on average
as interest rates rise I will not take
action that undermines the bank of
England's monetary objectives but where
there are non-inflationary measures we
can take to relieve the anxiety faced by
families we will do so
that's why on Friday I met the UK's
principal mortgage lenders alongside
senior representatives from the
financial conduct Authority and UK
Finance to agree new support for people
struggling with their mortgage payments
at that meeting I secured agreement from
lenders to a new mortgage Charter which
we're publishing today that sets out
what support customers will receive it's
been signed by lenders covering 85
percent of the UK market and provide
support for two groups of people in
particular
the first group of those who are worried
about their mortgage repayments if they
want to switch to an interest-only
mortgage or extend their mortgage term
to reduce their monthly payments they'll
be able to do so with the option of
switching back to their original
mortgage deal within six months without
any affordability check or credit score
impact
for most people the right course of
action will be to continue to make
payments on their current mortgage this
will always be the best option and will
always mean you pay less interest
overall
but this new measure means that people
will be able to opt for a lower cost
approach for six months with full
reversibility giving people the Peace of
Mind of knowing that they can try out a
new approach and still change their
minds later
this measure will take effect in the
next few weeks and means that for a
homeowner with a two hundred thousand
pound property with a one hundred
thousand pound outstanding on their
mortgage over 15 years they can change
their payments with no immediate impact
on their credit rating by extending the
mortgage term by 10 years which could
save over 200 pounds a month or moving
to interest-only payments which could
save over 350 pounds a month
this group of customers means that if
they're approaching the end of a
fixed-rate deal they'll be offered the
chance to lock in a new deal with the
same lender up to six months ahead
however they'll still be able to apply
for a better like for like deal with the
same lender with no penalty if they find
one until their current deal ends
this will provide people with more
flexibility and optionality to find the
best deal for their circumstances
the second group of people we are
supporting are those who are at real
risk of losing their homes because they
fall behind in their mortgage payments
mortgage arrears and defaults remain at
historically low levels with under one
percent of Residential Mortgages in
arrears in 2023 and at a lower level
than just before the pandemic
nonetheless for the families involved it
is extraordinarily distressing to lose
your house so we want to do all we can
to support people who find themselves in
such a challenging financial position
part of our strong regulatory framework
for mortgage holders Banks and lenders
already provide tailored support for
anyone struggling and deploy highly
trained staff to help such customers
support offered includes temporary
payment deferrals part interest part
repayment as well as extending mortgage
terms or switching to interest-only
payments
to supplement that we've agreed as part
of the mortgage Charter that in the
extreme situation in which a lender is
seeking to repossess a home there will
be a minimum 12-month period from the
first missed payment before there is a
repossession without consent
and anyone at all who is worried they
could be in this situation should know
they can call their lender for advice
without any impact whatsoever on their
credit score
lenders would also provide support to
customers who are up to date with
payments to switch to a new mortgage
deal at the end of their existing fixed
rate deal without another affordability
test and provide well-timed information
when their current rate is coming to an
end
taken together these measures should
offer Comfort to those who are anxious
about the impact of high interest rates
on their mortgages and provide support
to those who do get into any extreme
financial difficulties
the mortgage Market itself remains
robust and the average homeowner
remortgaging over the last year had
close to 50 percent loan to value
indicating most people have considerable
equity in their homes
Mr Speaker tackling inflation is the
prime minister and my number one
priority we said we would halve
inflation not because it was an easy
thing to do but because it is the right
thing to do and we won't Flinch in our
resolve because we know getting rid of
high inflation from our economy is the
only way that we can ultimately relieve
pressure on family finances and on
businesses and that is why we will seek
to remove inflationary pressures in our
economy and not Stoke them
that is what the measures I have set out
today will help to do and I commend this
statement